The first tattoo I got was this little guy right here.
It's based on this book that my whole family read,...
...everyone's got it on their wrists.
And it was right before I really had any tattoos...
...and so I wanted to make sure that it wasn't visible, and so I put it down here.
Basically it's about this seagull who wanted to be more than just a seagull.
My favorite tattoo is probably my new one, I really like this one,...
...took about three and a half hours, almost four hours.
And the worst part about it is that I'd be like this for so long and it was just bad, uncomfortable.
This one means a lot to me, it's my mom's eye.
This is my mom's birthday, seems like I have a lot of stuff to do with my mom.
Me and my dad got this one together.
This is a G, it's for my boy.
His daughter's name is Georgia, she has a brain condition.
And so, I got that for him just to support him, let him know I got his back.
This one's really cool, the story behind this one is, it's L L,..
..stands for "my head's low to lifted up,"...
...just to never keep your head low and always look for the better days.